fruits légumes vins épicerie caisse
après caisse les produits rejoigne les
voitures en ce début d'après midi six
commerçants de ce quartier de nevers
finalisent les commandes depuis deux
semaines ils ont mis sur pied un service
de livraison année tous tous des
artisans des producteurs et des
commerçants de proximité et nous
paraissait important qu'on le fasse
ensemble pour deux raisons pour cette
raison de solidarité et pour réduire les
coûts de livraison parce qu'on peut pas
aller livrer une baguette ou une salade
5 km chacun a sur des tournées dans un
rayon d'une dizaine de kilomètres autour
de nevers un moyen d'aller au plus près
des consommateurs et de limiter les
contacts
côté livraisons pour moi c'est aussi
alors ça a été clairement les gens qui
peuvent pas y aller et puis c'est
prendre soin des gens parce que
[Musique]
l'initiative est apprécié en cette
période de confinement se faire livrer
c'est aussi un geste de soutien de la
part des clients
faire travailler le commerce local je
trouve que c'est important dans ces
moments difficiles
voilà donc peut-être qu'en ce moment on
recommence et par la suite les
livraisons ont lieu deux fois par
semaine après commande par mail ou par
téléphone
une logistique supplémentaires mais les
commerçants n'ont pas hésité à franchir
le pas ça nous aide aussi nous à pouvoir
continuer notre activité
parce que même temps ouvert c'est on a
moins de fréquentation quand même
qu'avant donc du coup une perte de
chiffre d'affaires dont quant au montant
des charges et c'était à payer donc
c'est le seul moyen pour l'instant que
qu'on a trouvé pour maintenir l'activité
et puis surtout pour pour aider les gens
tous espèrent aussi que leurs clients ne
les oublierons pas une fois l'avis
revenue à la normale car le service a
permis de renforcer les liens dans le
quartier et pourrait même perdurer après
le confinement
112 mai